The addSeries method call is where we actually specify that we're going to
make a bar chart.
A quirk of the addSeries method, that the first argument
specifies a field to create categories for the chart to group the data by.
In this case, if we gave the method something like stage of each game,
then we create a stacked bar chart, or whichever chart we specify where it
facets the data based on the field, that you pass in as the first argument.
In this case, and we'll see in just a minute,
if we specify stage, we'll actually be representing the attendance for
each stage of the World Cup for a given year.
Since we want to first see the attendance across all games for
each year, we're going to pass in null,
which just means to not group the data on any other field.
The last step is to draw our chart and see all the hard work that Dimple has
done for us, here we just call the draw method on our myChart object,
which we added all of our axises and the series to.